foreign
we want to establish an amazing masjid
for the sake of allah in the country of
norway click on the link and donate now
for the sake of allah
so yeah so what i was going to say is
okay so
tell us a bit about yourself so we want
to know about be about yourself okay so
i think
because we're talking about one specific
thing i'm going to concentrate on that
yeah and i'm going to say i was born in
italy okay i was raised there and i was
raised with um you know let's say i was
i am like the typical you know yeah
the people you would see
everywhere now like being indoctrinated
by media and being indoctrinated by
ideal ideologies really
which are constructed on fallacies
really nowadays yes and
what i really always found a problem was
that most arguments yeah around
literally everything in life
always had emotional argument like it
was all always emotional motives there
was never logic or fact yeah and if we
take it literally facts don't really
care about your emotions do they yeah
so
i think that's what really stuck with
that that just got stuck with me and i
started to like
the moment i tried to separate my own
emotions which people nowadays like use
to like justify
everything they want to do whether it's
objectively right or not like whether do
it or not
i think
the moment i separated
the emotion side with the facts yes i
think that's when i started to like have
a plane base where i could construct
what reality really is in the dunya okay
so
from there i just started you know i
started to research into also it's very
difficult to kind of understand islam
when you're in italy for example yeah
it's very because nobody's muslim there
like nobody is so i was fortunate
because of course i was born in a muslim
family
but of course they never had the
um logical or the yeah
the vocal the vocal ability to kind of
portray the message logically it's more
like to someone
what does this mean don't worry so
someone who is like growing up between
like in a contrast between what's a
social norm yeah in their own world like
in their own country and what reality is
on the other hand which is of course
islam for me
because that's the only place place
where i found some sense you know so did
you was there a point that you left
islam or was there a point where you was
like i'm not sure i think i was like
in it like when i was in italy i never
really felt as if i was a muslim or
whatever so it's not like i ever left
islam i feel like i've never associated
with it so i've understood okay i have
understood because the only thing i went
like i only went far until like reading
the quran and that was it okay
i found out that
my sexual inclinations you could say
okay all
right heteronormative you could you like
they were not i was not straight okay
like technically speaking i don't i
don't believe in defining yourself with
these words in a sense that they
constitute your identity more than the
word muslim does really okay and that's
where
so of course it's a struggle for many
people because there's many people who
identify as you know it's not even
identifying they just feel that way okay
so it's more like an instinct rather
than a feeling
because okay what the word is like you
know the word gay is not defining you as
a person it's just describing your
biological approaches to some situations
in some circumstances okay and my main
problem was you know every time i would
research the question whether you can be
gay or muslim online
the answer was always that the answer
was always focused on sex yeah so the
answer answer was always focused on sex
in the sense that
people were always worried about whether
you can act upon it or not
but i never found that to be the biggest
issue there because my main problem
since the beginning was to like
understand what reality is
you know like you mean with the creator
exactly okay that was my main want me to
put your back down
um yeah yeah yeah yeah then put it down
for you
sorry yeah so do you mind giving me your
name or like uh hussain he's saying okay
you're saying
okay so
yeah so the thing is here it's very
important because the thing is when
anybody has these inclinations yep we
all have inclinations in different ways
and it's a way of dealing with it now
obviously as a person who had these
inclinations where you felt maybe the
attraction to the opposite gender
whatever it may be
there are people who go from different
routes yeah so the first one could be
allah made me like this yeah it's
allah's fault you didn't go down there
number one which i found very
interesting and i i found it very
admiring that you didn't go down that
route because a lot of people not even
just with the um
with your sexuality some people do this
with
the one party so they're like you know
when i want to party so what they do is
they feel bit guilty doing these sins so
they're like okay if i make myself
believe that god doesn't exist i'll
justify it to myself you didn't go down
that route you went down the route where
i mean i did initially you did initially
when i was like 11.
exactly
yeah
later on you made yourself you
acknowledge that yes i may have these
inclinations um but you didn't leave
islam like you said no yes i i don't
know what happened next when you felt
this stuff
i didn't leave the foreign of islam i
left it when i
came to the ayah you know luther i never
had any context about it okay that's all
i read because media was portraying
islam that way you know islam does this
to these people and this to these people
but you know if you get to the root of
it you discover that it's not islam
doesn't do anything to these people as
long as you're not doing it you know
publicly okay stuff like that which is
really unlikely that you would do that
you know exactly even in today's exactly
even that goes with like people who are
straight you know you're not going to go
and do intimacy in public and if you do
that you know they'll be a punishment
it's not like one of over the other you
get it like the concept of dinner is
dinner it was done in public what
happens in the house is totally separate
because you don't have any impact on
society so from there once when you
realize this realization it's very um
strong of you to acknowledge that it's a
sin yeah so you accept it it's like it
is a sin yeah so how did you deal with
it because there are people who may have
i think of course of course it was a
problem for me as well in the sense that
i had to be introduced to this issue the
same way everybody else had to yeah so
like for someone who has exclusively
these inclinations you know it might be
a bit hard because you have to what you
have to accept is that
there's no kind of outlet for you to
have really you you cannot it's fine you
know it's and i i understand it's very
difficult for some people and therefore
i can see why people take it to a realm
where they have to like
they take it to a position in which they
just justify it they say how can alive
like you know deny
these pleasures to a human being who
biologically has them yeah but you know
i feel like
i feel like at the same time it's like
this desire is not it's
i feel like everybody's given a
different challenges this dunya really
yeah true true what i mean so if you
believe in allah to begin with you
understand that yo when you're reading
those words where allah is denying this
to you when he's saying that you cannot
do it yeah
i think you need to have the perspective
in which you believe allah is real
therefore he knows what's right and what
isn't
and therefore you have to like take the
approach in which you simply have to
accept it but obviously this can i hug
you
please you know why because because you
know this statement you made
this is the essence of tawheed because
what you found in a nutshell is the
following you've said i have these
tendencies of towards opposite gender i
have options i can say allah made me
like this it's our last fault and i
leave the religion you didn't go down
that route you said look i have these
tendencies and i'm going to try to
battle them and i'm going to accept the
qatar of allah this is tawheed you
accept in the qatar of allah you accept
that good and bad come from allah you
are if you think about it even though
you have this test that you have with
many people can rebel many people can
say you know i don't even have an outlet
somebody who is obsessed with sleeping
around has an outlet you didn't and the
reason why i gave you a hug
is because i found that so profound and
strong coming from someone like you
because i've speaking to a lot of people
who have these tendencies yeah i
struggle to find people who are in my
situation who went this way exactly so
it's very unique and it's very
interesting because you know why when it
comes to this
which is trust you are having trust in
allah to a matter that you can not
control yourself and you're saying allah
you're testing me with this make me
strong you're worshiping him you
acknowledgingly exist there and you are
asking him for help and like you said
before you said you found happiness via
i think i think people
i think people what they do in the
beginning is that i think
they start to compare their desires with
allah as two equal concepts yeah and
that's this that's the mistake there
because if you do that
you're basically just trying to find a
way between the two where you can do
that and also believe in a line you know
but you're not just doing it to kind of
just for the sake of doing it but you're
trying to justify it within the
parameters of islam yeah yeah so that
obviously cannot work but i what i what
i suggest for people in my what i would
suggest for people in my situation to do
for example is to
to explore the situation with the
acknowledgment that allah is
indeed the one
he's the one above us he's like the one
you read about in the quran he is the
one who is like that's who has ownership
towards us yeah so when you have that
approach
when you get
like when you get deep into this
situation you
you basically you just need to try to
give you know what you know what it is i
think media makes it very difficult for
example for people to i feel like media
makes it extremely difficult for people
to find a way to reconcile this with
islam yes
but i feel like the only solution to
that which is not even that complex is
to just you know
try giving it up for allah
i think if you if you just try it you
will find more pleasure that way allah
says in the quran only in my remembrance
do hearts find peace so what that means
is sometimes we think pleasure and
things that we want
is we'll find in materialism so when i
look i was i was not muslim before party
girls all this kind of stuff i live this
lifestyle you hit a wall you hit the
wall of what's next i was pondering to
myself a couple of months ago i was
thinking i'm i'm nearly 32. some people
say i look 25 i mean that's normal okay
so the thing is here the the point is
this i was thinking can you imagine me
living that lifestyle till this age what
a boring lifestyle
going clubbing every weekend linking up
with girls it's boring bro it comes to a
point where you're just bored so the
thing is how do you actually find actual
happiness and peace this is where we
believe in the fitrah god almighty has
programmed us that we can only find
happiness in his remembrance just the
way in when we enter jannah the the
biggest pleasure is going to be in what
some of us think you know we're going to
get i'm going to get 72 virgins and you
know i'm going to get all the girls
if you think about him we are told that
we are the greatest thing that we're
going to look forward to is allah's face
yeah and his face the way his majesty
not the way we think about it yeah so
even in jannah we seek his face and in
this dunya we seek him so actual
pleasure doesn't come with okay i have
these homosexual tendencies if i can't
practice them i can't get the pleasure i
want no because allah says if you fear
me i will give you a way out from places
you can never imagine so that inner
peace bro sometimes when you have the
inner peace and the connection with god
almighty there is nothing in this world
that can match that
nothing so that's why it's important
when you said that about god almighty
and the connection and finding that to
me that is beautiful man i'm so happy
that i met you today other than that
other than that i feel like in the quran
it's quite clear you know i feel like
for people who try to find a way with it
yeah i feel like there's not really a
way for you to reconcile these two
things in a sense that you have you can
justify it yeah because in the quran
it's literally quite even even if you
like literally translate the arabic it's
quite clear what it's saying about such
people and you know such inclinations
sorry so i'm so sorry it's okay yeah
because i want to see the identity
because sometimes they recorded without
yeah oh no no it's okay okay so what i'm
saying is that you know some people
what i was saying
i'm so sorry so you were saying uh was
talking about the lord it's quite clear
in the quran you know that so for people
to you know come to the conclusion that
actually it's fine and you know allah
will still love you will still forgive
you even if you like justify it yeah in
islam parameters really yeah so
i feel like it's just impossible to do
that i feel like people need to first
acknowledge that yeah if you'll have a
look in the quran really i'm studying
the quran with the noman ali khan
yeah yeah and i feel like if you truly
have a look at it yeah you start to
realize that there's no
like you know even when we in the quran
even when the hypocrites are mentioned
for example
and how you know
they there's an ayah that says they come
into the light and they step out out of
their own convenience basically that
they accept islam only when it's
convenient for them to do so
and then they step outside of it when
they just want to do something that
doesn't adhere with quran and that's
what allah says have you seen the one
who takes his desires as his own god so
i feel like if you i feel like the
solution the main solution here would be
to put yourself outside of the box yeah
and look at your situation technically
yeah without involving your emotion so i
understand that it's a very emotional
it's coming from someone who is who has
lived this situation okay so i
understand the emotion can be quite
strong here yeah but if you look at it
from like an external perspective right
if you put your inclinations on one side
and what reality is telling you you know
what the you have realized that
subjective truth you've realized it and
you are reading the guidelines that the
subjective truth has given to you
and if those guidelines are not dealing
with your desires it simply means that
you have to give them up just like
anybody else has to give up other sins
you know it's the same exact thing
i don't think i don't think
homosexuality can be
i don't think allah is being unfair by
giving me a challenge which makes me in
my sexual inclinations it makes me
unequal to someone who might be straight
and is happily living their married life
i take it as a challenge you know i just
take it as something that i have to live
through and just like other people have
and i feel like when allah gives you
such a struggle in your life it's simply
because you can handle it exactly it's
it's not like
it's not like it's not like you can't do
it and when you have this mindset you
never fall into it yeah exactly if you
keep persisting and being consistent
with this mindset nothing happens yeah
exactly no it is we don't we don't
believe in the supernatural you know we
believe allah is there as an aide as a
supporter you know and he does say that
he will never give you something that
you cannot bear and the thing is and
i've seen that
because the the further i got away from
that kind of environment when these
things were being justified the easier
it got for me to deal with it yeah yeah
yeah yeah the easier it got yeah there
you go and i feel like it's gonna be
that inshallah it will be for that for
life like i don't know
inshallah what i mean is also that
would you say um
i feel like i might have some advantages
as well like me while other people might
have to you know get married while for
me it's a bit for me it's a bit like
unconvenient to get married because i
simply cannot yeah what i mean like
so uh what i was saying is that i i can
see an advantage in my situation
actually i can see more time to spend
with a lie in comparison to what you
know married couples have you got a
beautiful man wow man that's amazing man
i like i like the way you think bro i
like the way you break it down when
you're like okay i see the advantage of
the po you don't look at the cup half
empty okay half full and you're like you
know maybe somebody who gets married
will not have as much ibadah and
closeness with god i get to get that
that is bloody beautiful man
well i i'm i'm amazed i'm amazed by how
you think how you take that test and you
don't turn it into something where you
can blame god which you know logically
logically logically yeah someone can but
if you think about having trust in allah
etc you're taking this test and you're
just beautifying it with ibadah getting
close to allah
you know tawheed and all these things
that you're saying yeah and it's i think
it's amazing and i think that this is
one of the most amazing discussions or
people that i've met is you and i really
appreciate them i have to say